hello everyone and welcome to the
playoffs of the 2019 World Cup
quarter-finals it's a maxi Marshall a
gravure C's Levin R&M and the to
classical games between the two of them
ended in a draw so naturally here we are
at the rapid section and the first rapid
section where Arden had the white pieces
ended in a draw so this is the second
game where Maxine has the white pieces
and we do have a nice four of them it's
from the classical a classful match as
you can see lavender with the white
pieces as well as just enjoy that for a
bit you can see levin wears a purple
shirt here and this is 11 being
conservative usually it will seem in a
much more colorful addition as we didn't
know him to be the most colorful person
in any event so this is this is actually
very rare so that being said let's check
out the game Maxime with the white
pieces opens with efore we have E 5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to
c4 the Italian games on the board this
is a bit too high up and now Knight to
f6 the two Knights defense and now nice
to g5 that's a very nice idea but d3 was
played in this game with Bishop to c5 by
11 and now c3 with a6
castles by level by maxime in the now d6
so this is all a very theoretical stuff
with a 4 castles by black and then our
rook to e1 we often like to mention that
Knight to g4 with the idea of capturing
an f2 is nothing as black can just play
y can just play rook to e2 click away
the knight and the loop will actually be
useful there on the second rank so we
have Bishop back to a7 as usual
attacking the bishop in for later with
h3 taking the g4 Square from blacks
pieces and h6 black does the same with
Knight B to d2 preparing to bring this
night over to f1 and then offer a trade
off of dark square Bishop so with Bishop
to e3
we've looked at a eight and now before
they are further expanding on the Queen
side and now Bishop to e6 offering a
trade of lights worships with Bishop
captures rook captures and now Geary had
this
against our engine in the scene filled
couplet their game and wrought their
queen to see to was played by giri but
here we have nice to f1 now preparing
Bishop to e3 to trade the dark square
bishop s-- and MVL also had this game he
had it against poly grass in isle of man
tournament in 2018 where d5 was played
by black but here we have Queen to d7 by
11 developing the Queen preparing to
bring the other rook into the game and
it is as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so Maxime continues
with Bishop to e3 Bishop characters on
e3 Knight captures on e3 and now d5 it's
not only in the Sicilian that black is
happy when he can push d5 but also for
example in here with b5 now attacking
the knight and now well you could trade
here for example captures captures
captures captures and then move the
knight you don't really gain anything by
this so 11 just retreats with the knight
right away we have Knight to e7
and now c4 with further pressure further
pressuring the center with d4 11 decides
to close the center and now tonight's
the f5 and although this is now well it
is a monster night on f5 but there is no
need to eliminate it right away as the
White has no good follow up that night
it's a nice night but for a moment there
are no tricks here we have looked yet
getting the other look into the game and
now this night comes to h4 if the knight
is captured and I fire then this night
can take its place with nice to g6 now
going after the h4 night and here you
could double up black's pawn structure
here by playing captures captures but
then black eliminates the f5 knight from
from from is a very nice square for free
basically Knight h4 attack the pawn
you're gonna defend it and the black has
a very nice position now you can even
transfer the rooks over to the F file
so after Knight to g6 with g3 by white
with the idea of playing f4 at some
point now comes Knight captures on h4
Knight captures on h4 and Queen to e7
and now preparing to meet Knight to a5
with this nice infiltrating move Queen
to b4
so we have Queen the c1 by Maxime
now further preparing this f4 move and
now Knight to d7
making room for the f5 pawn with Queen
to a3 also offering a trade of Queens
and now Knight the c5 declining the
Queen trade with f4 by Maxine as planned
he captures on f4 and now Knight to f5
the Queen has to stay on this diagonal
to keep an eye on the knight on c5 so
Queen back to f8 and the now comes G
captures on f4 we've looked at f6 11
here prepares a very nice tactic and
rooked f1 just allowing the tactic so
here 11 played rook captures on f5 it's
a very nice idea because for this
exchange sacrifice you get to bring your
knight over to rook to e3 as it's it's a
very nice active idea for for black with
rook captures on f5 e captures on f5 and
then out rook to e3 from there your
attacking the d3 pawn as the knight also
attacks it you're attacking the h3 point
you can easily bring the Queen into the
game and it's just a very nice position
for blacks
so look 81 Maxime wants to get rid of
the other look as well and now while he
could capture on d3 and h3 both 11 first
place Queen to e7 he gets the Queen into
the game now with the idea of playing
rook captures sunny one with rook
captures on e3 Queen captures on III and
the believe it or not xi is completely
winning in this position but it's not
all that easy to find the winning move
so here the black king is in check the
white king is in check and Maxime plays
King to h2 but now I feel free to pause
the video and try to find the winning
idea for 11 in this position while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that the
Queen on a3 is undefended and you will
not be able to capture the night and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's actually nice thief or so of course
the knight cannot be captured because
the Queen hangs and what else are you
gonna do the queen is coming to g3 with
chair then you're going to capture on h3
I can come to f/2 it's it's really an
impossible position to defend for
example if Luke g1 defending it now you
get Knights to d2 and other thread is
nice to f3 check if you don't want to
lose the rook for example rook to g2 now
you get the knight to f3 check and now
if King to h1 you're just getting made
it check you have to block Queen
captures here is mate and if you don't
want to get made it for example after
this check you're good to go to g3 but
then again Knight to g5 I discovered to
check from the Queen the King goes back
and the now Queen captures on h3
with check King g1 now you go Knight to
f3 with check King f1 Queen to h1 check
Kings f2 and now after night to h4 this
rook is getting well you're gonna
capture the rook whatever you play for
example you just move it a Queen f3
check picks up the rook it's just a
terrible position for white but 11 did
not find in 94 I again will repeat it's
a rapid game both of them are below 10
minutes or maybe somewhere along the
10-minute mark so here Queen the e to
check first
now the rook is under attack with King
to g1 and now 11 should repeat Quinta
III check once the King moves again play
this knife to e4 move as it's again
possible but 11 goes for the d3 pawn
instead we have Knight captures on d3
and now Maxine goes B captures on h6
preparing a 7 a 8 to bring a new Queen
into the game so first 11 picks it up
with B captures on a6 and now Queen to
b3 here preparing Queen to d1 with Queen
back the e3 with check King to h2 and
now Queen to d2 with check with King to
g1 and queen to e3 with check with King
to h2 and here if Levin would play Queen
today to check we would have a draw by
repetition but 11 declines the draw and
he plays h5 he wants to play h4 and get
to this Queen to g3 move in
maxime says okay I'm gonna play Queen to
d1 and now you play whatever you want
and here there are a lot of good moves
for black you could go night to F - you
could go Knight captures on f4 for
example then if white offers a trade you
have this very nice night the d3
move and now white will be unable to
trade because if you capture then
already the queening square is protected
so black would be winning here so you
would have to play something like f6
allow the Queen trade captures captures
and now after let's say 95 you attack
the rook here characters you would get
this position where it's still rook
against tonight but black black has
definitely has compensation for the for
the exchange but here after Queen to be
111 played h4 now preparing Queen to g3
but h4 doesn't work so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
winning idea for Maxime now in this
position while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it
congratulations you have just eliminated
11 Arjun from the 2019 FIBA World Cup
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show
rook to f3 yep it seems that it's that
simple
I caught a glimpse of the live coverage
when Magnus crawls and saw this he just
said this is well it's a terrible way to
go down or something in something
similar to that not exactly that but it
like it was a it's a shame to go and go
down this way
oh but yeah now if you move the Queen
you just lose the knight on d3 so your
only option is night 2 f2 or night to
beat you to go after the White Queen
Knights the b2 is what Levin played with
rook captures Knight captures and now to
make matters worse you don't just go
into this worse end game you you're
gonna lose your passport as well so rook
to d3 we have nice to beat you and now
rook captures we have c5 getting the
rook away from the c4 pawn and now rook
the d5 attacking the pawn Knight
captures an a4 while defending the pawn
here and here ok it's 5 points against
411 is still up on pawn but he's not
going to be up upon for very long kingi
to Maxine starts again his king into the
game with King f8 11 does the same King
a3 with King East 7 pink the g4 now
comes Knight b6 attacking the rook if
you want to activate the night you have
to part with the c5 pawn so look at rest
on c5 and now King to d6 going after the
roku and if the rook moves of course
after the pawn but rook the a5 just
going out
pretty a sick spawn with a nightcap
Tristan c4 rook a person a sex with
check King to e7 and now King captures
on h4 so now it's Maxime who's up upon
and also up the exchange with Knight to
d6 and now
Maxime weights no longer he says okay
the the King and pawn and game is
winning so he just plays the simplest
move rook captures on d6 we have King
captures and now King to g5 we have King
back the e7 in here again with the
simplest idea just f6 check either you
know trading down the material if King a
fade in at Punk after sin g7 and of
course if you trade then King a5 and
black King has to move away from the
defense of the f6 pawn King f8 now
you're gonna capture and now King in two
points against Kingdom and one point is
of course completely winning so yeah
after f6 11 resigned and a very nice
victory for magazine for sherrilyn Grove
who advances to the semi-finals of the
2019 FIBA World Cup where he I believe
he will face a team or a job of and
being is still waiting for his next
victim
I mean opponent so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it a very tough
break for Levin who oh who almost again
made it made it to claim his spot for
the candidates tournament and it's still
not impossible for him to claim his spot
at the candidates tournament but it will
be extremely hard soon I once again I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Emiliano Panero a Chicago garand
club in Johannes Kurtzman for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous videos your
think all for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
World Cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and and so on so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest your day